Yeah, so my process for
sort of putting myself,
the methodology I like to think of
here is this sort of outside in view.
This is, you look at what your
product looks like to people
outside of your organization.
Most companies think about it
from inside out perspective.
That is,
oh we have these legal requirements, oh,
the tech team can only build this.
The design teams, and you add up
all of these different ideas and
thought processes, which make a lot of
sense within the bounds of your company,
but don't make a lot of sense when
somebody's looking at it externally.
This is why you find simple forms, like
a Contact Us form, including 20 fields,
because this one came from legal,
that one comes from marketing.
You have five things like this because
the database is structured this way.
And one very common technique,
not common but
very useful technique that you can have
to force yourself to think outside in,
is to actually have somebody role
play the role the role of a form.
And what do I mean by that?
If you give someone a form,
and you act like a human, and
they only are able to respond
with what the form says.
So as an example you can say,
hi, I'm Luke.
I'm trying to decide whether or
not I want to get a loan with you.
First name.
Okay, Luke.
Last name.
Wroblewski.
Gender.
Male, right, you can really start to
see how it doesn't make any sense as
a conversation.
If instead you were to make
that a real world conversation,
you'd say something like, hi,
I'm looking to maybe get a loan.
Oh, well what are you trying to buy?
Oh, well I'm trying to buy a home.
Is this your first home?
And, very naturally,
you can weave that process through.
And to go back to the original answer,
this name-value pair in the database,
it is not a human interaction.
It is a process of telling a machine
the requires fields it needs to
process a document, which generally
is not how we think about the world.
So that role playing can go a really
long way to helping people see
almost the silliness, if you will, for a
lot of the interactions we have online.